[Musique]
tous nos clients vont recevoir un sms
qui va leur proposer de prendre leur
température avant de rentrer dans le
train donc qui reçoivent ce sms avant le
avant le trajet ils arrivent ici ils
vont pouvoir revenir sur une des bornes
que vous voyez là prendre leur
température leur température et est
inférieur à 38,5 qui continue de façon
classique leur embarquement leur
température et simply supérieure à 38,5
nos agents d'embarquement qui sont
derrière pour avoir une petite lumière
qui va s'afficher sur leur sur leur
téléphone et on va alors allé voir le
client vérifier qu'il a un masque si on
n'a pas lui reprocher un masque lui
donner du gel hydroalcoolique et le
client peut continuer était tout à fait
sur une base de volontariat de façon à
ce que les gens puissent prendre leur
température s'ils le souhaitent c'est un
acte responsable un acte protection de
soi et des autres
bien entendu si jamais une seconde vague
arrive et que la législation évolue nous
serons en capacité d'implémenter
rapidement de nouveaux types de
contrôles on travaille en fermant vrai
qu'on m'empêche d'aller bosser mais
après si on est sûr que les masques le
gel suffisent pourquoi pas peut-être un
compartiment réservé dans le train
voir des personnes comme ça sans soi
tout seul c'est sûr ça suffit pas et
c'est un peu comme comme d'autres choses
on met des gros trucs qui rassure ou qui
ont peur mais c'est l'ensemble de la
chaîne téva regarder les mesures en
général qui s'enkystent situation de
masse qu'il est déjà obligatoire et le
gel ça dure que quelques minutes quand
il vaut protection propose